[Music]
[Music]
if you've seen elder ring all the way
through to the end then first of all
congratulations on your achievements
that is no small feat for a game as
challenging and massive as this one you
may also have some questions as to what
it all means did i get the good ending
or the bad ending after scouring through
countless item and enemy descriptions
lines of dialogue and so on i think i
have a pretty comprehensive picture of
some of the mythos behind the world of
elden ring and what its different
outcomes signify today i want to talk
about the age of the stars ending
specifically which is probably the most
talked about because well first of all
we are finally maidenless no more and
because out of all six endings this one
is probably the most ambiguous ronnie's
words as she brings forth her new age
are as cryptic as they are uncertain
there's talk of fear doubt and
loneliness and a dark path so what does
she have in store for the lands between
keep in mind that this is just my
interpretation it's very much possible
that i've missed or misinterpreted
certain things the amount of lore in
this game is massive and a lot of it
fractured and cryptic in nature if you
feel like i've missed something or you
want to give your own two cents on the
matter feel free to let me know down in
the comment section so we can all grow
wiser very well let us both learn
together
the night sky seems to play an important
role in alden ring everywhere you look
you can see remnants of stargazing
people mining for space debris a large
moon looming over the landscape and a
fearsome demigod who quite literally
held the stars in place with his power
over gravity what a badass as is common
in high fantasy the universe of eldon
ring does not function like our own and
we can find many clues from the story
writers which gives some more insight
among the starting classes in elden ring
is the astrologer who are said to be one
of the first to study the stars and are
also the precursors to the present day
sorcerers from the academy of raya
lucaria the ancient astrologers
discovered that beyond the stars of the
night sky lies a vast dark sea of
nothingness which they called the
primeval current it's also described as
a lightless void or an abyss on some
occasions it is believed that within
this void all life exists as one a sort
of singularity that holds all of life's
infinite possibilities from the void
stars and other celestial bodies are
born and these bodies hold fragments of
these possibilities also described as
residual life the astrologist theorized
that the very stars themselves are
essentially living beings life in a
primordial form yet holding a profound
wisdom and feigned cognition this
cognition is also referred to as the
wisdom of stone some of these celestial
bodies or pieces of it will eventually
rain down on the surface and when they
collide the residual life inside
fractures and evolves giving rise to
diverse and more complex life forms this
process is exemplified by some of the
creatures you may have encountered in
the lands between there's astol which is
said to be a malformed star born in the
lightless void far away the falling star
beasts found inside craters the
alabasters which are described as a race
of ancients who said to have risen to
life when a meteor struck long ago and
then there's the crystallines these
creatures are inorganic yet are alive
somehow and according to the shattering
crystal spell they are revered guests of
the sorcerers because they are the
living proof of the wisdom of stone and
the ideals of the primeval current the
sorcerers and alden ring are essentially
the scientists of this world they study
the cosmos at the raya lucaria academy
or hogwarts as i like to call it and
their magic practice which is referred
to as sorcery is derived from glindstone
pieces of crystallized space debris that
have rained down on the lands between
since time immemorial and are said to
house the very same residual life i
spoke about before these stones are
mined from caves or craters and use the
fashion and perfect spells and the
better your understanding of the cosmos
the more powerful your spells become
this is why sorcery spells and weapons
are commonly tied to the intelligence
attribute some saw the primeval current
as the holy grail of knowledge and
sorcery those obsessed with the abyss
even went as far as to replace parts of
their body or in some cases most of it
with glimstone crystals they believed
that through regression they could
harness the wisdom of stone and unravel
the mysteries of the abyss and draw
their magic from it also known as
primevo current sorcery which became a
controversial and forbidden practice in
the eyes of the academy the current was
apparently seen as something not to be
tampered with at least three people
including two headmasters have actually
been banished from the academy for
practicing this forbidden rite now there
is no text in the game that outright
confirms that the primeval current is
the origin of all life in the universe
but there is one piece of dialogue that
at least hints at this being the case
it's from an npc who's tied to the
questline that leads to the frenzied
flame ending and well just listen to
what she has to say all that there is
came from the one great
then came fractures
and births
and souls but the greater will made a
mistake
torment
despair
affliction every sin
every curse
every one born of the mistake
and so
what was borrowed
must be returned
melt it all away with the yellow chaos
flame
until all
is won again
so to break it down she says that all
there is came from the one great and
what was borrowed must one day return
until all is won again that sounds an
awful lot like the primeval current so
i'm guessing that she's probably talking
about the same thing followers of the
frenzied flames seem to believe that
life as it exists now is a mistake full
of pain suffering and division and would
rather see everything and everyone
disappear into the void from whence it
came which is exactly what happens when
you choose the frenzied flame ending if
my interpretations are correct it means
that those who study the cosmos
essentially discovered the true origin
of life itself problem is this discovery
and ideology is in direct opposition to
the greater will and the system it has
created the greater will is a being
classified as an outer god and is
responsible for the creation of the
elden ring as well as the earth tree
what outer gods are exactly is not
entirely clear it's some sort of
invisible divine presence likely far
beyond human comprehension call it
cosmic or interdimensional it's clear
that it's a being that operates from
outside reality as we know it hence the
outer part it's very lovecraftian which
is definitely nothing new for a
soulsborne title and yes there's more
than one outer god present in the lands
between at least six or seven are
theorized to exist each with their own
goals and motivations however only two
or possibly three have an actual impact
on the ending of the story and the
frenzied flame is one of them the
greater will happens to be the one with
the most power and influence in the
lands between at the time the story
takes place but it wasn't always like
that it is said that long ago it sent a
golden star into the lands between
carrying one of its representatives the
elden beast which is also the final boss
and after its arrival it started
establishing its own order many of its
followers are highly religious their
system of belief also known as the
golden order is based on the idea that
the greater will is the one true god and
anything that contradicts that belief is
deemed heresy
that
is a work of heresy its incantations
bear no lineage from the earth tree
it's a system that although based on the
concept of order is also extremely
intolerant ever since its inception it's
been at war with everyone around it even
enacting near genocide in some cases
those who stood against the house of the
artery or posed a threat in any way were
either wiped out forced into exile or
converted their beliefs and with every
victory the influence of the greater
will grew until it had little to no
adversaries left the only reason why the
academy escaped a similar fate was
because of an unexpected marriage the
marriage between the acting governor of
the academy queen ranala and a prominent
champion of the urtry ratagan of the
golden order who allegedly fell in love
on the battlefield because of this an
unusual alliance was formed between the
two ronnie was born from the marriage
between ranala and radigan and grew up
among the sorcerers during this alliance
over time she grew to despise the
greater will and all it stands for her
heart lay with the moon and the stars
and did not want to be controlled by a
god that rules with an iron fist even
since before the shattering of the alden
ring she had secretly been scheming to
bring about a new order one that would
replace the greater will entirely it's
also revealed that ronnie had a secret
mentor we don't know much about her but
she is described as a snow witch now
when the term witch is used in elden
ring it's usually not meant to be
positive this isn't like the harry
potter universe where males are wizards
and females are witches for example one
of the people i mentioned who were
kicked from the academy was selen an npc
who seems friendly at first until you
realize what she's done turns out that
she is also extremely obsessed with
primeval current sorcery even going as
far as to kill fellow students and
experimenting on them fusing their
bodies into one giant mass after being
banished from the academy and going into
hiding she was given the nickname the
grave and witch i don't necessarily
think that the snow witch had the same
malicious intent but the fact that she's
labeled as a witch does suggest that she
was at least practicing magic that was
deemed controversial or dangerous in the
world of sorcery it's also stated that
she taught ronnie to quote fear the dark
moon hence it's highly likely that her
secret mentor is the one who set ronnie
on her path to bring about the age of
the stars ronnie's questline essentially
sees you helping her in tying up the
final loose ends to make her new age
become a reality this is also why she
was so invested in the underground
cities of noxtella and nokron those who
built these cities were driven
underground and exiled when they
rebelled against the greater will not
only did they develop a weapon capable
of hurting the greater will but just
like the sorcerers they had a deep
connection with the cosmos
long ago the knocks invoked the ire of
the greater will and were banished deep
on the ground now they live under a
false sky in eternal anticipation of
their liege of the coming age of the
stars and their lord of night when you
stand before the elden ring and have
completed ronnie's questline instead of
restoring the alden ring and ensuring
the survival of the greater will you can
instead summon ronnie's spirit after
which she dissolves the alden ring and
ushers in her new age but what exactly
is the age of the stars and what does it
mean for the future of the lands between
well let's listen to what she has to say
i thought i might expound a little
further upon the order i envision
mine will be an order not of gold
but the stars and moon of the chill
night
i would keep them far from the earth
beneath our feet
as it is now life and souls and order
abound tightly together
but i would have them at a great remove
and have the certainties of sight
emotion faith and touch all become
impossibilities
which is why i would abandon this soil
with mine order
words thou come to me even now
my one and only lord
the way i interpret it is that ronnie is
creating a universe closer to that of
her own she says that she will keep the
stars and moon far away from the earth
implying that before the age of the
stars they exist at a much closer
proximity i don't know if that's true i
mean they seem pretty far away then
again the fact that they constantly
invade the lands between also speaks
volumes like she says under the greater
will life souls and order are bound
together which is true it's it's right
there right there believing in god is
not exactly hard when it and its rules
are literally staring you right in the
face in her age there will be life there
will still be order but that order will
be so far removed from mankind that
absolute faith and knowledge of its
existence will become an impossibility
creating doubts fear and loneliness and
i don't want to get too philosophical
but it is kind of like our reality as
far as we know at least right now we are
alone in the cosmos with a lot of doubts
fears of what happens when we die and
questions of where we came from and why
we even exist some suggest that the dark
moon she mentions is yet another outer
god but i honestly have my doubts about
that i couldn't find any text that
specifically says that the dark moon is
an outer god not to mention it kinda
goes against what ronnie stands for i
mean she purposely rid herself of her
empyrean body for the exact reason of
not wanting to be bound to an outer god
anymore to free herself from those
shackles and walk her own path a path
that leads into the dark abyss of the
cosmos and the lord of night mentioned
before likely refers to you the
protagonist because in every ending you
become the lord of something elden lord
lord of chaos and in this case you
become ronnie's lord as you set off into
the cosmos together my current take is
that the dark moon is supposed to be
symbolic a harbinger if you will if you
look at the landscape of the lands
between there's two prominent entities
that stick out the ur tree and right
next to it a moon a moon on the verge of
turning dark perhaps meant as a sign
that the age of the earth tree is coming
to a close and the age of the stars is
about to commence if you choose that
ending of course whether or not you
found this to be a good ending really
depends on your point of view do you
think it's better to have god right
there in front of you dictating your
every move or would you rather embrace
ignorance and the mysteries of the
universe or maybe you just want to press
that history eraser button be sure to
let me know which ending you find the
most satisfying i skipped over a lot of
details when it comes to ronnie herself
and her backstory because well that
could easily take up an entire video on
its own luckily there just so happens to
be a certain bandit i know who made an
amazing video on that exact topic so if
you will please go and check it out
ronnie has one of the most interesting
and equally mysterious character stories
in the entire game so it'll no doubt be
worth your time thank you all so much
for watching and i hope you found my
first eldering theory to be entertaining
a big thanks to wes and sabrina for
joining my patreon and to wavery and
ashley hall for becoming a channel
member you guys are amazing i must
apologize for the time it took me to
make this video elden ringlore is a lot
more complicated and convoluted than
zeldalore it was honestly a bit
overwhelming i may have also been
hopelessly addicted to playing the game
the past weeks which wasn't exactly
great for productivity either but hey at
least i had a good time with it and that
is all for now this is dawn signing off
and
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you